Speaker 1: We have the latest inflation numbers,
these numbers have been much anticipated,
there were rumors flying around that year
over year inflation.
Once March 2022, numbers were added in would
get into the double digits, over 10 percent.
And that didn't happen, and we're going to
talk about expectations.
We're also going to talk about what the number
means.
But first, we all know if we participate in
the American economy, meaning if you buy groceries,
go out to eat.
Own a vehicle, a gas vehicle.
Pay utilities, I mean, everything is more
expensive, my electrical bill is up.
My grocery bill is up.
People who have gas vehicles see that gas
is more expensive.
We know intuitively because of our experience
in the economy that prices are up and the
question is how much and in what sectors.
And we now have that information.
And inflation has indeed increased by the
most since 1981, and the consumer price index
is up 8.5 percent now.
There are people confused about what this
means, but the reporting is also confusing
when we talk about an eight point five percent
price increase.
We don't mean that in March, prices went up
for 8.5 percent.
However, a lot of the reporting makes it seem
that way.
I mean, look at this Yahoo Finance headline,
which says inflation rises by the most since
1981 as the consumer price index jumps 8.5
percent in March.
I understand why some people are confused,
but so that you know, this number means that
in the year ending March 2022, the consumer
price index is up 8.5 percent.
The previous number was February to February.
The new number eight point five percent is
March to March.
Prices didn't go up 8.5 percent in March.
They went up eight point five percent in the
year ending March.
Now it's on the one hand.
Why am I talking about this so much?
On the other hand, if you don't understand
that you don't have any idea what's going
on and there's people all over Twitter and
all over my feed saying, Can can you believe
it?
Prices are up almost 10 percent in one month.
No, they're not.
These are high numbers.
These are the highest inflation numbers since
1981 for a one year period.
But unless we all are on the same page about
what this means, we're really not going to
get anywhere.
And the reporting doesn't doesn't make it
particularly more clear.
Now you look in more detail at the numbers
and you see that there are a number of different
areas that that are sort of leading this.
Some of the biggest contributors to the increase
were food.
We know that we know groceries are up.
We joke a lot about mango prices.
But but grocery prices are up, shelter rents
and home property properties, real estate
and gasoline.
And the index tracking gas prices surged up
eighteen point three percent month on month
in March, comprising more than half of the
total monthly increase.
So half of the increase in prices in March
was gasoline alone.
And in February, gasoline had a 6.6 percent
monthly increase.
So this this is if you want to have a real
conversation about this, you kind of have
to get away from the politics because there's
a lot of this is just Joe Biden's fault.
And of course, there's global inflation.
Gas prices are up everywhere.
The most important aspects of this, to me,
are kind of twofold.
One is the reaction.
Why is the stock market up today if these
numbers are so terrible?
And as of right now as we're filming, the
stock market is up significantly today.
The answer that we are taught and we can all
judge whether it makes sense or not.
Is that the market had already priced in that
the numbers could be even worse?
There were rumors inflation could be above
10 percent.
Now the actual economic forecasts were exactly
this.
They were eight point four percent.
We got eight point five percent year over
year.
But because the market now has the certainty
that it's not going to be worse than expected.
The market is doing well.
Some people just don't care.
OK, but if we want to analyze that, that would
be one thing to think about.
The other aspect of this is there are lots
of people pushing hot takes on social media
that this isn't the real number, that the
real number is above 10 percent, and that
the metric of the consumer price index doesn't
accurately take that into account.
Well, that's an argument that you can have
at any time.
Very often when unemployment numbers come
out, you will see people come out of the woodwork
and they'll say, you know, when in the unemployment
system, you stop looking for work, you're
no longer considered unemployed.
So the number is not accurate.
That's true, but that's been a reality in
the unemployment system for 40 years.
Going all the way back to Reagan is that closer
to 50 years now?
The point is, you can't cherry pick when you
point out the limitations of a metric to try
to make a point about only the latest numbers.
That's dishonest.
This is the way that we've measured these
things for a long time.
My prediction and my prediction is worth as
little as everybody.
Else's I mean, I'm the first to tell you,
humans are terrible at making economic predictions.
My prediction and this is just an opinion.
Is that we're basically at the peak here of
inflation and that we're going to start seeing
a slow decline in year over year inflation
may maybe starting next month with this month's
numbers, but more likely in the next two to
three months.
That's my prediction.
What might delay it a little bit would be
gas prices in general tend to go up over the
summer, more people driving, taking road trips,
etc. and if that's the case, it may push it
off even a little more.
But my sense is, within the next four months,
we are going to start to see a decline that
that unless something dramatic, changes should
continue.